It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Are you awake?
I feel like we're extra loud today, huh?
Maybe.
Ruffians, thank you for joining us today for our 156th episode!
Thank you!
And it's a brand new week too!
Yes, brand new week!
Your week, your hour is having a week.
It's time to wake up!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's Monday.
It's Monday!
And that means it's FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah!
But if you still love FUWAMOCO Morning, you're new!
Yeah.
Well, if you're joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday today.
AKA FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Oh no, that's a bad sign Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO!
That was sudden.
That surprised me.
What was that?
We're gonna start the week off on the right paw!
Say it with me!
FUWAMOCO!
Hi.
No bad things happening this week.
It's gonna be an even funner week than the weekend last week.
I forgot.
I was so surprised I forgot.
There's been another Pero sighting!
Really?
Okay, well, this is for your sakes, okay?
Safety.
Let's take a look at what Pero was sighted.
Okay.
De-den!
Hi!
What the heck?
The Pero turned into a bottle of salad dressing.
Salad dressing?
Huh?
Wait, but... It's not popcorn.
That's not salad.
Popcorn is not salad.
I don't know.
I don't think you should be tempted to put the Pero dressing on your popcorn.
No.
Yeah, but you know it's a very fancy packaging.
Yeah, you know.
Pero does sort of a convincing job.
No, I still think you don't.
Popcorn is best consumed as it is.
Without salad dressing.
What about butter?
Marjoram.
Whatever the ruffians think is best, but not Pero salad dressing!
Salt is normal.
Mayo, Pero, no!
It's gonna be on.
You have to put salt on popcorn.
I need to put sugar on it.
What's that?
Put sugar on it.
Caramel, caramel, caramel works too.
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't know.
I don't think you need this, alright?
In those situations, you know, you're like, ah, I don't need this, but I bought it from the grocery store.
You return it, right?
So maybe you should just return the Pero dress to the store.
Yeah, before it goes bad.
Right.
I'll get all moody and... sort of... fuzzy on the inside.
Why do you know you drop it?
What's the options?
Options!
BAU BAU!
Be careful Ruffians!
Can you return salad dressing?
Why would you not be able to?
Especially when it's not.
This salad dressing is not to my taste buds.
Then you just wash it down the sink, right?
BAU BAU!
Wow!
There was some very big news at hololive over the weekend!
Ai-senpai, Akirose-senpai, Aki Roseto!
She reached 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
We just wanted to say a big congrats to our dear senpai.
It was like so hard.
You know, Akirose senpai is so amazing and sweet.
We really love her singing and her atmosphere.
Her original songs.
Everything's so much.
She's so talented.
I don't know, just listen to her sing too.
Her karaoke too.
Howl!
Howl is... What about Heroine Audition?
What about Rosie the Lamp?
There's just so many.
Every song is amazing.
Every song is different.
It's perfect.
Now everyone at hololive JP is over 1 million subscribers on YouTube too!
That's crazy!
1 million!
Big congrats to Akiro-sensei!
Bye!
We're so happy to be able to talk with Rizzolino during Hanami, so... We got to ask her a bunch of questions, too.
Yeah, all these questions!
Yeah, but you know, we just can't wait to see even more great things happen in the future, so... Always amazing, exciting updates.
Yeah.
Akiro-sensei, congratulations!
Yeah, big big news!
But on the hololive EN side, there's also something to look forward to today!
Very soon!
Wow, that is... De-den!
Ina-senpai!
She's revealing a new outfit today!
Is it here?
Today at 6PM PT or in the morning in Japan at 10AM JST, she'll be sharing a brand new outfit with us!
More announcements?
What's more announcements?
I'm excited!
What could it be?
It looks very cute!
Oh my god!
It's a side ponytail!
Side ponytail probably!
Very refreshing!
You know, it looks very chill.
What else?
What else are we thinking?
Casual look?
Casual maybe?
I don't know.
Maybe it's like a school uniform.
School uniform?
FUWAMOCO I'm imagining.
Yara Ina-senpai!
But again, it'll be happening at 6PM PT, so we hope that you'll check it out and see what Ina-senpai's new outfit looks like, as well as her new exciting announcements too!
I'm really excited.
Why?
What could it be?
Leopard print!
We don't know!
Ina-senpai leopard print, I think that one could work well.
Right now it's just purple and orange, we don't know.
Purple and orange.
Leopard print's kinda like orange, right?
We'll have to see!
We don't have long to wait!
BAU BAU!
I'm super excited now!
Oh my gosh!
And Ina-senpai's outfit is always so super cute!
We just finished the latest chapter of Enrico of ENigmatic Recollection.
Chapter 2, Chains of Fate.
In case you missed it, it sprawled over one week and all of us EN lovers participated.
Crazy things happened, you know.
We were able to save the kingdom of Lobesto, but many things didn't quite work out.
As we expected because there's a little bit of a cliffhanger at the end there.
We've been seeing on Twitter there's been a bit of a uproar.
Uproar?
A rebellion would you say?
A rebellion!
Wow at the very end of the season there is a wonderful animated short fully animated!
Featuring all of us hololive EN members!
But surprisingly, Advent.
What's wrong with Ambe?
Something's kind of funny.
We're seeing some pretty evil things, you know?
I don't know.
Somehow, I think some Adventrix follow listeners.
What a surprise, huh?
It is surprising, huh?
You know, it's surprising what could be evil.
We are innocent puppies, though.
We are thrown in the sewer, but we're innocent, though.
We're not evil.
Committed crimes?
No.
No crimes?
We're protected by you.
No cell.
Not locked up.
No.
Yes.
It's just a big misunderstanding, okay?
What does this mean?
I'm at the end of this.
The next ENReco chapter.
Chapter 3 was announced as well.
Broken Bones.
Broken Bones?
Do you remember what it's called?
Broken Bones.
Well, we'll have to look forward to the next chapter of ENReco.
TBD.
Not Broken Bones.
Broken...
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Thank you FUWAMOCO listeners!
Thank you for supporting all of us!
BAU BAU!
You had a lot of fun!
So much fun!
Moco-chan, you had some interesting dreams recently.
Now, um... I will pervase this.
Uh oh, Ruffians.
This dream happened, you know when you just sort of fall asleep a bit and you're like... I was like that.
Dream.
Do you have that happen often?
Dream segment is back!
Yeah, Mococo dream, yeah!
You have that?
Yeah, speedrun dream, yeah.
Yeah, the speedrun dream where you're like, was I sleeping?
Oh, but I had a dream.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Well, I had a dream!
I had a dream about Gigi!
Oh, Gigi!
Yeah, and I feel like, although this was a dream, I feel like it could have been real.
I also saw that Gigi had a dream about Calli-senpai.
Why does this always happen, huh?
It could be a nightmare.
If Gigi is in it, does that mean it's a nightmare?
Automatic nightmare status.
I don't think it was a nightmare.
But!
Gigi was probably a nightmare in my dream, huh?
Okay, well!
I'll start the story here, okay?
So, we're listening.
So, in my dream, Gigi, she had discovered the hidden legendary recipe to the best meatballs.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
So they needed to get her legendary meatballs.
And at one point, she was running with them on a plate.
And then, she said this is a no-no.
I can't control it!
It was GG okay!
And she tripped and she landed onto her meatballs.
She had tears in her eyes.
She sort of looked up like... And then,
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Well, they were safe.
They were safe.
She protected them with her life.
I protected them with her life now.
That was my dream.
What you did, you both!
Yes!
I don't know, I feel like this could be real though.
I feel like this could be real despite the fact that maybe I would make meatballs more likely than Gigi, but we'd have to ask her.
Right, I don't know.
I think Gigi might have a legendary meatball recipe, no?
If you kind of blur your eyes, Gigi just kind of looks like a big meatball, right?
What?
Is that the secret?
Is that the secret to her recipe?
Become the legendary meatball.
She has the same sort of color of a meatball.
A shiny meatball.
Well, that was lucky.
It's a good thing she protected the legendary meatballs.
It'd be bad, you know, sharing the legendary meatballs with the rest of the world.
I know.
The world would be destroyed.
Great.
Too much.
Too much for it.
Save the world.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Can't control the dreams, right?
It's what happens.
It's just word, okay?
You have to believe.
BAU BAU!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we had some nice time to ourselves recently.
I say ourselves, but it's not just ourselves.
Because we got to see Biboo and Nerissa!
Lots of Biboo and Nerissa just hanging out, you know.
And actually we went over and had another party with Nerissa and Biboo all of a sudden earlier.
That's maybe why we're maybe a bit late.
You know, and then we just hung out with them the other day too.
We got to spend a bunch of time with them.
We're super duper happy!
We did have Nerissa's famous nabe.
We promptly burned our mouths on the kabocha.
But it's because Nerissa was so nice.
She had one nabe that had onions.
And one nabe that didn't have onions for us.
And FUWAMOCO we kind of showed up a little bit late.
And so she was like, okay well I'll make it now.
So it's nice and hot for FUWAMOCO.
I love FUWAMOCO so much.
It's burnt in my mouth.
There's green onion in it!
Oh, it wasn't in there!
It was in a different pot.
I love onions.
But you don't!
I felt lots of love.
And we brought ingredients too!
Moco-chan was like, don't bring anything!
Nerissa has everything!
And it was all eaten, so... Right!
Right!
You don't!
It was so yummy.
It was nice you know.
And for dessert we had strawberries and watermelon.
We did not bring crickets.
No.
We could have though.
We could have.
But you know Nerissa was eating the watermelon and chit-chatting.
And Nerissa was crossing her legs.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Wait, I'm not.
You can't be so stinky, right?
What?
No, that was just watermelon.
It's watermelon.
See ya!
Bye!
It was just funny.
I'm late but we had a nice big long group hug.
We were all being silly and you know there was a chair open in the corner and we were like this.
Shiori!
You know in our hearts.
Yeah we had it in our hearts.
Yeah big cuddle puddle yeah.
Yeah.
Did you give them the omiyage we did?
We did!
Yeah, Nerissa really liked hers.
And we got all excited to be able to, you know, have fun and chat together.
Yeah.
And we forgot that Biboo didn't open hers.
So we'll have to see what she thinks if she understands what it is.
Right.
Maybe it's a bit complicated.
But she's a sleeping rock.
Yeah.
By the end we always have to roll her out of there high.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, did she open it?
Not quite yet, but we can look forward to it, right?
But it was just nice, you know?
It was being silly together.
Yeah, very silly.
We went on a walk too together, didn't we?
Yeah, so... We hope we can hang out all together more.
And sing with other senpai and kouhai too!
You know...
Warm inside now from Nerissa's nabe.
Yeah, and a hug.
BAU BAU!
Although, you know, we talk about this big long group hug like it's not a regular thing.
Oh, true.
It's a pretty regular thing.
Pretty regular thing, huh?
BAU BAU!
Speaking of regular, should we take a look at some of our regular corners here?
First, with the Doggie of the Day!
Yes!
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Shen!
FUWAMOCO!
Look!
Look at that!
Sleepy Queen.
It's so pretty!
Her little paws are so cute.
And the royal pillow.
Pillow only for Shen.
So cute.
Moco-chan, how does Shen bow-bow?
I feel like she sounds like Princess Ebony.
You know, like, bow-bow.
Is that Princess Evaniya?
BAU BAU!
Cat.
Raccoon plushie.
Mouse.
This is Shen.
She's the Doggie of the Day.
Yes!
BAU BAU!
I know Shen might look like a queen here, but she's super duper friendly and always welcoming to new people.
Yes, and a good queen should be hot, right?
Yes.
More friends means more head pats, right?
Oh, right!
We definitely get that.
Yeah.
Understood.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I've seen many of your vlogs recently.
Thank you for sharing them with us!
Let's take a look at one vlog on today I went on a walk.
De-den!
Dinosaurs!
Oh my gosh, that's too cool!
FUWAMOCO and the dinosaurs!
Thank you for taking us here with you!
BAU BAU!
See all the bones!
I don't think we've ever seen dinosaur bones before.
Stegosaurus.
That's a dinosaur!
I think you know my favorite dinosaur.
Moco-chan, you like the Triceratops?
I like the Triceratops.
You're not being influenced, are you?
No, I like the Triceratops!
I like the spiky, the spiky, the spiky dinosaur.
The spiky one.
I like the dinosaurs that look funny and are in the water, too.
Those ones.
Yeah.
And the fluffy ones, too!
The spiky one.
Maybe the fluffy ones are hot.
BAU BAU!
And we have next a Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
What are my favorite things to do with my siblings and introduce them to anime and watch it with them to see their reaction?
Have you two ever done this with each other?
Anybody otaku?
If so, what's one of your favorite ones to get people to watch?
I don't know if we've done this with each other.
No, not really.
No.
But you know, many, many, many, many hundreds of years ago, you know, there was a time when sometimes we want to share the anime that we like with the demon dogs from Demon God Dog TV.
So you know, you try to sit down, you know, let's watch this.
This is really cool.
You better watch this.
Let's watch it.
You like it.
It's my choice.
Yeah.
But then, you know, they don't really pay attention.
And then, things happen and they're like, oh, oh, I, I, I was talking, what was that?
What just happened?
FUWAMOCO in this situation is... No, no.
You missed it, you missed it.
It's your fault.
I'm not explaining it.
We're not going back.
No, no.
We're personally attacked, why are you not watching it?
I'm watching!
What?
I brought you here to watch it and you're not watching it so now it's your fault!
Do you feel how I love this?
Maybe this is a bit high.
That's the coolest reaction, thank you!
High skill issue!
Maybe just a bit hoarse, huh?
Yeah, we went all over all together.
We were at Calli-senpai's.
She wanted to show us that movie.
The one movie we were all sitting down watching it.
And then nobody was watching it.
And we were just talking and screaming over it.
And she's so patient and then explaining it.
The prestige, thank you, the prestige.
She's explaining it.
Explaining it over and over like the whole movie.
She's just explaining what happens.
I'm like wow, that is not us.
No, that is not our reaction.
Patience.
Very patient.
Wow.
I'm like it's okay, Calli-senpai.
We'll watch the procedure here another time.
We were trying very hard to follow.
We were, we were, yes.
You know, but...
Yeah, I feel a little bit nostalgic and impressed at the same time.
But I think you know our favorite one to get people to watch.
I was recommending School Days to Subaru-senpai recently.
True, but I think movies are also good too.
You know?
I would like to see Subaru-senpai's reaction to school days.
I feel like she would.
She watches a lot of anime.
Right now she's watching Fate Stay Night.
Isn't that an interesting choice?
School days is the next step, right?
It makes sense.
We're waiting for Subaru-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Surprise?
I don't know.
We'll see.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
We're always waiting for more questions of the day!
Doggies of the day!
Your walks doesn't have to be the walk of the day, but you know, a walk.
I walk.
Or, you know, you happen to see Pero, it's best to let everybody know.
So, please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Got it!
Thank you!
And we have another stream coming up!
Pretty soon, our next gym is De-den!
Metal Gear Solid 3.
Snake Eater.
Yeah!
We're continuing playing Metal Gear Solid 3 on the PS2!
Recently, you know, we got some more fashion choices.
They help us do the camouflage thing, which is helpful because it helps do the stealth thing sometimes.
CQC.
I got it this time.
CQC!
What does it mean, Moco-chan?
Combat.
Quarters.
Horse.
This week is the unofficial PS2 week!
What's more on PS2 is Advent!
We're gonna be playing some Jump Box games all together over on Biboo's channel.
It's been a while.
It's been way too long.
So we're looking forward to some extra silly moments there.
And then we'll be playing Fatal Frame for the very first time on PS2, the legendary horror game.
Join us for the beginning of it all.
Yeah, and you know, we'll see how that goes.
A little scary, but PS2 comfy.
I don't know if you have to look at the ghost.
At the camera.
I really don't like cameras or windows or doors.
Well, we'll see how it goes.
And in between, over on Nui-senpai's channel, is the Animal Tower Battle Tournament!
This is the second time that she's hosted it.
The first time was very interesting, very surprising.
It's a simple game where you have to stack animals on top of each other to make the biggest tower and beat your opponent.
The first one crushed them.
The couple loses.
At FUWAMOCO, we're pretty good, right?
Ruffians, we put it together before you know it.
It's a simple but tricky game.
So we hope that you'll see us rise to the top.
The top of the Animal Tower over on Ruri-senpai's channel.
And then back to some Fatal Frame we saw.
Thank you Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is...
BAU BAU people!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ming!
BAU BAU!
Frankccino!
Owakami Yuki!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Add to every other Ruffian out there.
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!